paul oui là rien d premier a été le
ministre de l'intérieur christian bonnet
vous allez l'entendez vous allez
également entendre une réaction de
raymond barre qui se trouvait à lyon
quant à christian bonnet et le premier
ministre je suis rendu immédiatement sur
place avec mon directeur de cabinet
monsieur vallini le prophète police
monsieur somveille plus hautes autorités
de la police parisienne
nous avons rencontré les représentants
de la communauté nous partageons son
indignation et s'y plie la communauté de
considérer qu'à la durance le ministre
de l'intérieur réagit elle si la tête un
jeune israélites
mais je suppute jeunes d'israélites de
ne pas provoquer une escalade
pour tous ceux qui ont été les victimes
je rentre sur le champ à paris de
manière à pouvoir examiner avec le
ministre l'intérieur
les mesures prises une par pour
rechercher ceux qui sont coupables de
cet attentat est d'autre part pour
éviter le renouvellement acte aussi
odieux
ce soir nous d'avant nous dire que un
pays démocratique qui respecte est la
tolérance qui est fidèle à liberté ne
peut admettre des actes de ce genre